اذا اسوء
السيناريوهات باتت ورده من مع حركه طالبان
التي توصل حملتها لانتهاكيه والقمعيه
لحرمان نساء من التعليم والعمل او حتى
ابسط الحقوق
فعدموا منح الفتيات والنساء حقوقهن سيكون
له عواقب وخيمه على تقديم خدمات الصحه
والتغذيه والتعليم للاطفال وفقه منظمات
دوليه ومراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
انقذوا الاطفال والمجلس النرويجي للاجئين
اكدوا انهم لا يستطيعون الوصول بشكل فعال
الى الاطفال والنساء والرجال الذين هم في
امس الحاجه الى المساعده في افغانستان
بدون موظفاتهم وهنا ادينا الاتحاد
الاوروبي والامم المتحده والولايات
المتحده بشده قراره البان وقالوا بانه
سيؤثر على تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
وجميع اعمال الاغاثه في المرحله المقبله
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتينا لبنان
فقد اكد بان قرار طالبان سيعطل تسليم
المساعدات وقد يكون مدمرا لافغانستان
[موسيقى]
في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
افغانستان سيؤدي الى تعطيل المساعدات
الحيويه والمنقذه لحياه الملايين
[موسيقى]
بدوره عبر الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه
من قرار حكومه طالبان تعليق عمل النساء في
جميع المنظمات غير الحكوميه بافغانستان
فرضته الحركه قبل ايام قليله على التحاق
الفتيات بالجامعات